think big do you like that wind up hit
that deep that you'll nasty beat it's
again affected you so Jenna Julianne
podcast a mega graphic in the promise
drops mic we just you spit on yourself I
rapped welcome back to the gen Julian
podcast everyone Steve another episode
hanging out with us we talk about Jenna
Jillian things amongst all the other
things thank you for joining us this
week yeah this episode is brought to you
by headspace meditation made simple guys
get rid of all that anger get rid of all
that stress well I just said that like
you an angry person you're not everyone
has anger and stress but you can get rid
of it with headspace it's guided
meditation go to head space.com slash
Jenna Julianne try the take 10 program
and meditate guided for free our other
sponsor this week is mid-roll what
mid-roll is is basically a company that
we work with that helps us get sponsors
for the podcast so you know what I'm
saying now like reading the sponsor what
what they want you know you guys to know
mid will gathers sponsors that they
think you guys would like and what
they're asking you this week is to take
a quick survey and what the survey will
do is basically make sponsors that
you're interested in so if you take that
survey you're bound to find sponsors on
this show that you will generally be
more inclined to I don't know follow up
with or be interested in so they're
asking you to take a five-minute survey
very easy very quick there's also a
possibility you could win $100 Amazon
gift card girl yeah
so I go to pod survey comm /jj to take
that survey we really appreciate it the
sponsors make this podcast for you for
you so on - Thank You chef so points
important yeah exactly uh thank you to
our sponsor Thank You sponsors alright
Julian go for it okay so I mean I don't
want to
I want to preface this little
conversation we're not going to make a
giant long podcast about this but I want
to preface this little conversation with
I've never met the fine brothers I don't
I mean I think I think I've met maybe
said hi to them when I went with you to
do react but I've never actually liked
me I don't think they know who I am so I
want everyone to know that I'm giving
them the benefit the doubt as human
beings you know I I I assume they're
finding the games they're AB only ever
heard amazing things from youtubers
about them today
was that a pun they're fine human beings
Wow that was a pun and it's not intended
but I'm gonna pretend like it was but
the reason I want to talk about them is
because they they are a little bit under
fire recently as the last couple days
and it's because they've released or
kind of announced react world which is
in essence the fine brothers for those
who don't know run around a YouTube
channel and a company called the fine
brothers entertainment and basically
what they do if you ever seen youtubers
react teens react kids react they that's
their thing they basically find people
of all sorts of different genres to
react to all sorts of different videos
and that's been there on their channel
for years and years and they've done
amazing edit there I think 14 million
subscribers now it's a massive massive
channel and what they did is they
announced something called react world
which in essence is licensing their
specific show so their licensing teens
react youtubers react elders react
things like that as entities that people
if they want like say you wanted to you
know have your elders react to a video
if you wanted to call it elders react
and have that be the format you would
now have to license it through the fine
brothers and they're under fire because
well basically you know reaction videos
were around before they came around
before they even had a YouTube channel
reaction videos existed and now it seems
like they are in a sense you know I mean
they talked about not wanting people to
get ripped off and that they're not fans
of people stealing content or
ideas and so they want people to license
their shows and pay them in order to use
them and I think a lot of people have a
problem with this because the whole like
spectrum of YouTube everyone takes a
little something from here and they're
like you watch videos to do your
homework
to see what's going on and then in turn
to make your own content I'm not saying
you watch videos to rip them off but you
learn you know and a lot of lot of
reaction channels exist on YouTube and I
I don't think they're going after just
people who are reacting to videos like
say h3 h3 or gray day under a like
things like that I don't think they're
just going after people to react I think
they're trying to just like capture a
subset of people who want to make videos
that are just like to find brothers but
in reality before their announcement
this week it would have been free to do
so
and now it's not what I do have a
problem with which I will say because I
don't you know I don't know how this is
gonna pan out I don't know what's behind
it I don't want to rush to judgment but
what I do have a problem with is is the
censorship and what I mean by that is
when they announced this project or
thing whatever you want to call it they
were on the video page on their channel
they were police in comments they were
they were basically deleting multiple
multiple comments that was you know
we're pissed off at the whole thing and
there's screenshots in evidence of it it
was it was just some censorship going on
and that's that's the thing that I feel
like a is like it's it's kind of like an
admission of doing something that you're
not supposed to be doing or you're not
proud of her you know you're not happy
with and B it's it's not right you know
YouTube as much as you're allowed to
delete comments on your page it's it's
not what it's for you know that this
made it to the red front paid on
multiple subreddits but namely our
videos and that's where you can find a
lot of information because you can't
delete I mean they can't delete comments
up there so I don't know is I just think
it's a
it's definitely interesting and it's
definitely something that people are
going to be very very aware of like I
said I really I feel I feel bad trying
to rush to judgment or trying to
understand what what's behind it or why
this project is happening or what this
whole idea what sparked it but it
doesn't ya know I'm just I mean I'm
trying to be as impartial as I can
because I don't 100% have all the
information I don't know the guys they
seem nice yeah can't throw my -
absolutely absolutely um I know the fine
brothers they're nice guys benny and
rafi they're pretty dope I've done them
for years and I have done an episode of
youtubers react and I think that it's
pretty well known within the YouTube
community that you know I haven't like
explicitly made a reaction video in the
past so I've never you know had to have
any sort of confrontation with them but
I do know that they aren't too fond of
other even other youtubers being like
I'm making a reaction video because I I
do think that they they want to hold on
to that within the internet space which
is fine I've never felt any strong
desire to be like oh here's me reacting
or whatever and I understand that they
have grown a business entity around
react series yes I don't think that
they're claiming that they invented it I
don't think that they're claiming that
they want to copyright the word react or
the idea of reacting they want to
copyright the show format so that people
in other countries that speak other
languages can take their brand and then
create it in other areas that in and of
itself seems relatively harmless to me I
don't know that they needed to make a
video announcing that I think that they
thought oh well you know some Joe Schmoe
over in Germany is going to see this
video and be like yes I'm interested in
that I think that there are other ways
to do it without you know laying out
your business plan for the general I
agree I agree I don't know why they did
that well I mean there's lots of reasons
you get X
closure for your business but I also I
feel conflicting about it because you
know obviously on a surface level to
copyright a format is really hard on the
internet and I'm not sure that it's even
worth it because I'm not I'm not a
business person but I'm very bad at
business i I'm the type of person that
until I had people helping me they're
like hey will you do this for free and
I'm like sure like I'm not smart about
yeah you're not business minded because
I just don't care yeah I think that it's
difficult on the internet to understand
which direction to grow your business in
and this is something that they've
decided like this is a feasible way to
grow our business without having to you
know make more television shows or more
YouTube shows because they're only two
guys yes they have a giant team around
them but like how far can you expand
before you're like alright we need to
break into a global market here I get
that what what I'm having trouble
sitting with is the reason that people
love the Internet is because it's
democratized right anyone can pick up
their camera and their laptop and make a
youtube channel and create something out
of nothing I have a problem with them
being like ok well if anybody wants to
do this ever they need to go through us
or else you're going to have problems
basically that takes away the spirit of
the Internet
you can't just film an upload now yeah
imagine if see Frank or you know anybody
had copy written jump cuts or someone
had copyright copyright in the format of
a late-night talk show like I think that
what makes the internet thrive is that
we're all in it together
and that no one is licensing anything it
is very frustrating when you see Jimmy
Fallon be like all right here's the
whisper challenge
like if somebody copyright [ __ ]
challenges we'd all be so [ __ ] right
now or copyright the format of a podcast
everybody would be [ __ ]
yeah and I don't think that's what
they're trying to do essentially but it
is in essence sort of what they're doing
well I think the point you made about
you know the internet thriving on
this kind of system is a really good
point because in their video they cited
America's Got Talent versus Britain's
Got Talent and that's so different
that's TV like it's literally the an
entirely different format process a
system and business that's why I have a
problem a little bit with them trying to
do it in the internet space I think it's
admirable because it's never been done
before so we're all gonna watch and
learn and see what happens but I think
it's you're saying all like Oh team
internet like this is great for
everybody which is often true when
someone bust down a door and breaks down
wall it's good for all of us doesn't
feel like every accomplishment that
someone from like the internet
accomplishes and then it's happy for me
well because it means that's more
opportunities for everyone absolutely
when someone takes you seriously like
conference' for example just got I
forget what it's called but his um heard
well yeah label yeah he got approved to
now be in the Grammy recording artist
little panel so that he gets to decide
who wins excuse let see when someone
accomplishes something like that bust
down doors for everybody sure about what
is possible and what you can do in this
space as a person that makes their
living online what I think that they're
doing though is they're they're making
it seem like this is great for everyone
and this is fair for people on the
internet because we do get our ideas
ripped off and we have no rights to them
because they're just ideas and we're
just people
we're not giant corporations that can
file a lawsuit hold on I understand that
but they're adhering those ideas to
old-school television formats yeah so if
if you are in a new media business and
you're adhering to old Hollywood
standards I'm not sure that the result
that you're gonna get is what you want
usually I'm saying absolutely cuz
they're coming at it from that that
angle
exactly I mean you imagine you know you
made your ear how to trick people video
right and then you made a couple other
videos and you made a rant right to
camera rant you're like hey I want this
to be my thing nobody can make it to
camera rant sitting on their bed talking
to their webcam
and two until they pay me and license it
through me and like not only is that not
even feasible and it's not it's
completely like the opposite of how the
internet works but in a world like this
is just like hypothetically if you did
that right
imagine the massive amounts of less of
female or otherwise rant vloggers who
would exist now they just wouldn't exist
because you get inspired and the whole
system of creating on YouTube is I make
this somebody watches it and they're in
some way moved or inspired or or
something turns on in their brain when
they watch it and then they show
something to the world and then someone
watches that and it makes everything
work and when people rip [ __ ] off they
get reamed like it's like a
self-sustaining system if you rip
someone off it's come you want
democratize exactly you're gonna get
called out for it the comments section
will ream you if you rip people off you
won't you won't just be okay so the fact
that they're not they're not adhering to
that like it's almost like an unwritten
rule like don't rip people off you know
that's not how the internet works take
take ideas learn things and be inspired
don't repeat a lot they're taking it to
another level where they're like well if
you rip us off we're going to sue you
you know what I mean so it's like ah it
just feels so anti Internet to me well
exactly and that's what I think they are
coming at this from a business
perspective like how can we protect this
entity that we've created and I think
that's you know it could be a good thing
for all of us in the future who knows
but it's also a dangerous line to walk
in that yes it's been frustrating to
have ideas that you know you can't
licence you can't do anything with and
people are just free to rip you off and
make money off of it or even just take
your videos I think that's a way bigger
problem people actually taking your
videos and uploading them to separate
channels into Facebook and just in their
entirety
like that's a problem that's that's
something that's a problem that we need
to fix what we're trying to solve isn't
really a problem right I think that the
beautiful thing about the internet is
anyone's allowed to make anything and we
solve police and we are
our self poise that's that's that's one
of the most important points here is
that it's it's like an ecosystem and it
kind of just maintains itself you know
that the thieves well most of them get
weeded out right now Facebook is kind of
throwing a wrench into that but you know
the thieves get weeded out you you
inspire people it's a community you know
back each other when they do good and
you back each other when they do bad
it's a whole thing and no you know and
here's the thing like I said I've never
met the fine brothers they seem like
nice guys if they're watching this I
want them to know that there's no any
sort of like ill anything towards you
guys we are really just trying to
analyze the situation and I feel like if
we weren't doing this we wouldn't be
being honest to our podcast audience um
you know I understand that you're not
just a YouTube channel you're not just
some kid in his bedroom making videos
every week
you're an entire corporation and you
were a big one so I get that part you
know I mean like I understand the
feeling of wanting to protect what
you've created especially on such a
large scale I'm just not so sure that
this was the way to get the internet on
your side about it you know right well
when we talk about well just the natural
progression of entertainment film
television internet you know well radio
is in there somewhere but people started
watching the internet because it seems
real it's a hundred percent real it's
just regular people with a phone or a
flip cam or [ __ ] you know flip
recorder and it's just sort of like
they're home movies and that's what
YouTube is then people started to create
a show like it was youtubers not me
whose gears before me but people that
created the idea of uploading on a
regular basis and asking people to come
back that you're going to be there
you're going to upload things that that
was an idea created just by people and
people would go to their channel and
watch their videos every single week and
then soon maybe that turned into a
format of how much time you you were
going to spend what exactly a video was
about what you were going to do in that
video this is all completely created by
people on the internet to the point
where now like there
somewhat of a format of what makes a
channel a channel or a YouTube video a
YouTube video you know that there's
sometimes there's an opening or an end
card or you know it's this amount of
time where if it's a story time video
it's like this or if it's a challenge
it's like that you know there's
definitely formats that have been
created but as a community and a culture
as a whole and even now people are
getting very upset from watching YouTube
being like this is [ __ ] fake like
these pranks that I thought were real or
fake these people that I thought I liked
are fake there's a lot of fake stuff
going on you know it's not it's no
longer this I have this you know flies
on the wall I've you of your life
anymore half of this shit's [ __ ] fake
never clickbait and you're just trying
to get me to watch it so you can get
paid because now everyone knows that you
can make money on the internet you're
right
you know virtual people are becoming
very skeptical of YouTube and videos as
a whole because for good reason they
don't believe that what they're getting
is genuine anymore just like on
television when you realize like oh what
the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] like this [ __ ]
big what the [ __ ] like all these reality
shows like this is scripted why are
there [ __ ] writers remember when that
was the thing when you're like I just
saw that there's writers on Survivor
what the [ __ ] is this yo and your mind
explodes 10 years ago whatever it's
happening on the internet now where
people are like I'm getting you're right
we're in that we're in that trend right
more trustful
of what I thought was real and now I
don't like it and what I think the you
know I'm trying to think of the word
that I'm thinking of but like the
business efficient the corporate
corporate advertizing of the internet
which I think might be inevitable you
know you might have to do this but you
you wouldn't expect an Internet person
to I can't say that because they're
smart business people maybe it is a good
idea
but I do think that the corporatization
of Internet companies you know they have
good reasons there's a lot of money
involved for big companies like that
there's a lot people is all lives
there's a lot of things at stake you got
to do what you got to do
protect what you've created and I get
that but regardless the corporatization
of YouTube as a whole is damaging the
community and the people that come there
to create to watch to hang out to do
everything because now you realize that
it's exactly what you didn't want to
come here for you know yeah what drew
you to YouTube in the first place
the real the you know just seeing other
people's lives out of genuine curiosity
the voyeuristic aspect is being taken
away because now you know like oh well
people apparently aren't free to just
sit down and make whatever they want
anymore
now there's rules yeah well you know
what you said emphasizing that the
Internet is changing right now yeah it's
important it is because it we're not
living in 2009 right you know it's very
different than it was it's you know it's
just one of those things element I'm
very very interested to see how it plays
out I'm interested to see how the whole
you know everything plays out in YouTube
like you know a year from now things are
going to be so much different just like
they were a year ago YouTube bread-like
things like that like stage what Jenna
always says and you always say this and
I cannot emphasize enough like how well
this hits home is a year on the Internet
is an eternity yeah and you know what
she means by that is is in internet land
in YouTube in the world maybe any new
media new media but you know we talked
about YouTube is that's where we live a
year goes by and so much can change
whereas you look at TV a year goes by
yeah maybe they're shooting in 4k maybe
I don't know it's like there's very very
little whereas the internet [ __ ]
everything has shifted in one way or
another in one year and let you know we
always talk about how there you know
there is no real path for a youtuber
right now because it's currently being
paved the construction is happening
right now yeah for an internet for an
Internet person so yes people know that
you can make money as a
they don't know where that exactly goes
people are transitioning a TV to film to
writing books whatever but they don't
know where this path is going to go
which is you know it's it's a crazy
thought the fact that we're all in flux
right now we'll take the vine community
for example and I've said this because I
have a lot of friends that are Viners
that are grappling with the idea they
all seem to think that vine is dead
every flick Viner that I know they're
like naughty vines like a dead man look
you got it we got to figure out
something else to do but everything so
film television the internet and then
there's vine which i think is like some
of the newest or snapchat some of the
newest music worms do it yeah some of
the newest forms to gain an audience on
the internet like YouTube for us you
know anyone that grew an audience on
YouTube it usually happens over the
course of a couple of years or you know
one year if you really [ __ ] go things
yet yeah but still you need to be
uploading regularly and creating what
you want to create on a regular basis
and it does take some time for you to
grow that vine it was like wait these
people can go from no one cares to 11
million followers and three billion
[ __ ] loops and now you have a career
exactly and to imagine that happening is
outrageous right like that's [ __ ]
insane to me and then a year of their
time is infinitely faster than a year of
our time the infinitely faster that is
exponential
YouTube is TV on speed vine is the
YouTube on speed it's like everything is
constantly getting quicker and smaller
and we saw what was interesting from
someone living in a world on YouTube
that is a little bit slower than the
vine world is you could watch according
to them according to Viners you watch
the entire ecosystem go through a rise
and fall yeah you watched it go from you
know just weird people uploading
whatever to this is what's popular oh my
god this is hysterical to revine for
revine to everyone putting the same ad
on their vine to now everyone
vine and it's sort of back to like a
[ __ ] show you watch the entire lifespan
of YouTube happen over the course of
three years yeah exactly here it's been
very interesting to watch and to watch
all the people on vine be like whoa okay
now that I've accomplished the hardest
part which is just getting an audience
just getting people to care which people
VAX leon der estimating how hard that is
you're just getting people to give a
[ __ ] about what you have to say why
should I [ __ ] care it's very hard to
then being like alright now that I've
done the hardest part what can I do with
my life to sustain that and they don't
have an answer a lot of them are doing
YouTube doing you know the same thing
that all of us on YouTube are doing like
which direction should I go it's hard to
know because no one really has done it
except for us yeah you know you don't
have a concrete path it's very
interesting you know but it was really
cool to see vine go through like an
entire lifespan and now everyone sort of
like well I guess I'm just gonna look at
YouTube channel I'm gonna [ __ ] do
this and like this or something there
was like standard of the time right yeah
because they had to that their platform
is not innately monetizable you can't
just go on there and get adsense for
your loops they needed to do those brand
deals which of course turned all of
their audiences off from them it makes
them mad when they know that they're
watching a commercial and sometimes
you're tolerant of it but unfortunately
because they can't just make a vine
everyday with a little you know the
money coming in yeah you got to do what
you said yeah that's I mean that's
obviously a key difference right but
anyways I digress what I think is
important about what's happening with
the fine brothers is that regardless of
whether or not you agree or disagree
with what they're doing yeah it's
interesting to watch it's never been
done before and it will help or hurt all
of us in the long run
absolutely well whatever it does it will
make it might not even check does I feel
like I feel like in some way there's no
way it's not gonna affect us something
about it is going to change something
even if it's miniscule it's going to
have a little bit of a
effect no no doubt about what I hope
doesn't happen is if you know I hope
that they're successful whatever they do
because I like them they're friends of
mine they're great guys I
they've already been successful in a lot
of ways I hope that they're successful
in what they're trying to accomplish
which sounds to me more infringing than
what I think it really is I don't I
don't think that there's as much of a
problem is what the uproar is making it
seem like I think they're literally just
trying to find people in other countries
to make react shows yeah you know yeah
in a fair way I agree which that's why
I'm saying I don't think the mission
statement is bad
right I mean when you listen to it from
a certain perspective it sounds horrible
think that's entirely when you think
about it though from a logical
perspective I literally think they're
just trying to find people in
Switzerland in [ __ ] Japan to just
make fair really meals yeah you know um
I forgot I was gonna say but anyways
what I hope doesn't happen is that they
are so successful in doing that that now
every YouTube channel somehow either
feels the need to have a common set of
precedent there to grow their audience
or you know is forced to that's a scary
[ __ ] copyright a format it's
horrifying
scary thought you know I'm sorry I mean
like when you're explaining the Internet
to someone who doesn't know what the
Internet is you know and and they're
like you make a living just you know
making whatever videos you want and
you're like yeah and and and they
they're stuck on the idea of like TV you
need to get approval you need to get
signed on to a network you need to get a
pilot up soggy people to accept it and
we have networks on you know I know I
know not talking about networks I'm
talking about India I'm talking about
independent youtubers okay and it's
important to understand that the biggest
most paramount difference from the
internet and TV is that it's
democratized like you said you can do it
yourself you don't need anyone's
approval you don't need to pay money you
press upload and it's done what this
could set the precedent for is
terrifying because it might take that
away or it might take steps towards
that way like what what you just said
it's horrifying you know every every
person every creators going to find a
way to cover it something and then
suddenly you log on YouTube and it is TV
it is not YouTube anymore right bull it
is sort of getting there you know it's
it's that that's why it's scary right
you know because it it seems like it's
true and it's but it's scary it's scary
for creators it's scary for you know
audiences and it causes you know stress
and worry but you can get rid of that
just going to headspace and you'll be
able to meditate just for ten minutes a
day trying to take ten program on
headspace the app you going to hit
space.com slash Gen Julian and get a
link to download the app and once you
download the app you you try there
program take ten meditate you know
guided ten minutes each day and you will
absolutely see an effect it's thousands
of years of scientific research
thousands of years of tradition have
incorporated meditation and that's for a
good reason meditation works
it truly does it takes away stress it
has it helps you with your relationships
gives you a clear mind and it really
like ten minutes
everyone's always with their phone get a
pair of headphones and you can do it
right on your phone anywhere you are if
you're in the bathroom at work I've said
this before
sounds like kind of weird but you know
if you're having a bad day at work
take that thing into the stall and
[ __ ] meditate for ten minutes I mean
that's what I'm talking about
give it a try but a headspace calm /
Jena Julian and give it a whirl
seriously and let us know how you like
it because I've tried it and I can't
tell you how nice it is it like while
I'm doing it I'm trying my best not to
think of how much I'm enjoying it
because you really need a like you know
you need to put your mind towards it but
um you know in the world will work
constantly on the screens it's very nice
so thank you headspace for sponsoring us
mid-roll guys if you haven't already
maybe take right now it's a five-minute
process go to pod survey comm /jj and
you take the survey like i says less
than five minutes and every month they
send out a $100 gift card on amazon so
you can win that gift card and it keeps
you know that what mid-roll does as a
company why we work with them is they
make the podcast free for us and that's
that's um
we want you guys have content for free
we want to give you [ __ ] to consume and
you can eat it all up and then not have
to pay a bill off to put you know what I
mean
so go to pod survey comm /jj and fill
out the survey if you have if you have a
second we really appreciate it
it will help you because it will make it
so we're not advertising old people
homes we're giving you as you can give
you good sponsors that you would want to
use so thanks again to our sponsors and
thank you guys for listening yeah well I
mean Wow
while you were you know doing our
sponsors for the podcast I was thinking
of something a little relevant that I
wanted to say so when we started the
podcast it was you know just for fun we
started out on laptops you know who the
[ __ ] knows Argos in 2014
yeah and no expectations you know just
gonna do it 15 yeah I want to in 15 I
don't know no it's 14 it's gonna be two
years in August yeah sorry I didn't mean
in our to cry um but what we wanted to
do was make sure that we were since
you're going into a space and I've
already set up sort of format what is
this format you know what's the
appropriate length of time you know what
are you supposed to do during it you
know they when we started a podcast the
podcast format already exists absolutely
so we adhered to that format and as time
went on and we got people that wanted to
sponsor us which was good because would
you pay off these [ __ ] mics and [ __ ]
yeah um you know what's an appropriate
amount of sponsorship you know we didn't
create the format of you know you have a
sponsor in the beginning in the middle
and then you mentioned them at the end
we're adhering to a format that's taller
respecting and informal exactly whenever
you're going into a new format you
respect the sorry-looking yeah you
respect what has already been set out of
you you can play with it you can push it
you know you can do whatever within it
but you do need to acknowledge that
there is a format same with this twitch
stream when we started on Twitch you're
accepting donations you're like what the
[ __ ] is very bizarre to accept money
from people for streaming but it's the
culture
is worse it's the culture of Twitter and
you need to do your homework I
understand you know the people that are
already in the space what do they do
what are what's their thing like how can
I be respectful of the established
community without stepping on anyone's
toes respecting the format instead of
just barging in there and being like hey
guys here's what I'm [ __ ] doing you
know [ __ ] everybody what I think is
happening with you know the fine
brothers and what they're doing is
they're taking a format they've already
established it on the internet and
taking what everyone agrees is the
format on on the internet which is we
make shows you watch it for free you
might have to watch an ad yeah and now
they're saying like we would like to
turn our backs on what feels like you
know the Internet as a whole and be like
we want to license this we want to now
adhere to another format and I imagine
if you know if I was a person in Japan
and I was like I want to make a react
series I've seen this wildly popular
react series in America and I would like
to make it it would be very difficult
for me as someone with a Wi-Fi
connection and a camera and a microphone
and you know some people to sign a
waiver to decide that I would like to
give the fine brothers any of my profits
from making that series just because
they did it first I'd be like no I'm in
Japan and I would like to make it myself
I don't understand why I can't do that I
think something I really think I hope
our audience takes hold of what you just
said and and really understands the
weight behind it is you know you're
you're talking about going on a new
platform looking around seeing how it
works and respecting the rules whether
they're out there or whether they're
unwritten there are rules for every
platform like she said for podcasting
there are we to our sponsors but it's
completely and the fact that Jenna is so
quick to respect that notion that you
need to respect cultures of new
platforms even if it means having a
brand on her podcast if you guys know
Jenna she doesn't do any boy
instead none zero on her Channel and so
a brand deal or a sponsorship is
completely foreign but the fact that
we've accepted it is a testament to how
imports yes for the podcast for twitch
yeah I mean the donations it's a
testament to how important it is to
really really understand what you're
getting into and not just come in there
like oh I know what I'm doing I'm gonna
do it my way no you're not well
understand the pros and cons exact
scenario and like it's important to
think about that when you talk about the
finebros in situation because it doesn't
feel like you know they've been around
30 you there youtubers tried-and-true
but it doesn't feel like this decision
is necessarily representative of them
respecting the rules or something like
that mm-hmm
you know yeah I mean I I've had a lot of
Viners in particular ask me just some
you know general advice about how to
start on YouTube and my advice is always
the same you know just do it and then
just make sure that you're consistent
don't upload a video and then upload one
three months later yeah that's not gonna
help yeah
you know just pick a schedule whatever
it is and make sure that you say to that
for as long as you [ __ ] can or want
to and that if ever there's something
that exists that's already been done the
YouTube community for the most part
thrives on credit we're really happy you
know or the most part absolutely we're
really happy to just say like hey if you
liked this it's already been done on
this channel Gina and Jessi literally
every challenge he's ever done we say
Gina and Jessi did this right yeah
because we know as people that are
constantly getting actual feedback from
actual people that watch your videos
yeah unlike television or film you know
when you wait until someone writes a
paper on our magazine article about your
[ __ ] movie
no we hear from every single person in
the comments immediately and so somebody
on YouTube does a challenge we know that
people are gonna ask you to do it
because they want to see you do it yeah
so what's your choice there you're just
gonna [ __ ] ignore everybody like you
can totally can nope
but no big deal at all but I mean every
once in a while they're fun to do who
the [ __ ] cares
and I think as a whole our community is
cool if you do something even has a
tribute even if you're like I really
like Epic Meal Time I want to make a
[ __ ] epic Meal Time tribute charity
comedy whatever I don't want the other
week to howtobasic the tribute it's like
it's it's it when you when you're
compelled from another person's content
to like do that or to tribute them or to
shout them out or credit them that's the
greatest thing ever because it keeps the
system running right and I can tell you
as someone look I'll get people to send
me a link of like here's me mildly
annoying my dogs I know we love that it
it's as a person that's like deep in the
YouTube community this is my home and I
consider the internet my home where I
want to stay and there is no ladder that
I'm trying to climb I'm trying to stay
on the internet forever yeah which I
don't think is a popular opinion it's
one of those latter machines and the
jammers going nowhere you're just
climbing the Stila yeah um I makes me
genuinely happy to see other people take
something that I've made actually make
what they want to make absolutely I mean
I you know what recently last couple
months I'd have people like you know
every once in a while will send me on
Twitter or whatever like you inspired me
to make this and and I mean every once
in a while because it doesn't happen a
lot but when it does it's cool it's like
a time-lapse video or something similar
or derivative of the idea and I like I'm
always so happy to watch that and so
excited like what that boils down to is
that that genuine dare I say reaction
that you're having
is sign here before you in here before
you say just kick is not ya money-driven
no you don't look at that person's video
and say look at all these views of then
you know get getting money off of my
idea how dare that of course it's coming
from the spirit of democracy on the
internet and freedom of speech and
uploading and you know making whatever
you want to make that's why there's a
reason why you might watch a video
that's a direct ripoff but a tribute to
your idea they at least gave you credit
they mentioned you which it makes you
feel like cool and special you're like
this is great
but if you're coming from a
business-minded place for that you don't
think like that you see here's this
person taking my idea and making money
off of it and this is wrong yeah I can't
a hundred percent say that you know a
react formatted show is the same as
someone also mildly annoying their dogs
I might be coming I might be coming from
a different place if I created a show
yeah I don't know how I would feel but I
can't imagine that I would ever possibly
look at someone else's show and format
and whatever and feel threatened to the
point where I I need to copyright this I
would I would be like good for [ __ ]
that man do you I'm still gonna do me
because my goal has never been to grow
as much as I can't even grow my business
yeah make them make the most money
possible you know just expand expand
expand because every day that I wake up
I get to do what I want and somehow have
enough money to pay some bills and feed
myself I'm living the dream
that's why I'm a bad business person
every cent and what people need to
remember is that you as a human being
and as a creator and as a personality
that's proprietary no one can be you you
know you can make a rant video just like
Jenna but you will be you and she will
be her and that's that's 9:30 because of
I dress tea
exactly and I was discouraged from the
get-go because I was like oh never be I
just taken she is nice and smart useful
and you guys are so much alike as in
that she's still [ __ ] going
she's intruder
this whole that's that's what I love
about the Internet is just because
someone else is doing something doesn't
mean that you can't still exist and I've
said this since forever like there's
enough room on the internet for
literally everyone everybody if everyone
makes a channel and does exactly what
you do I don't believe that it's
threatening you in any way I don't know
not at all because you know there's a
self policing ecosystem there are ideas
everywhere and there's opportunity every
single time you go on yeah and you know
to play devil's advocate to what the
fine brothers are trying to do which
again I want to emphasize I think that
they should be able to do what they want
and it's going to be very interesting to
watch and it could help everyone in the
long run and I like them as people and I
respect them as business people and
internet people respect them
I do too family I would like to play
devil's advocate to the corporatization
of that and say I believe we might be
better off as an Internet community just
letting things run as they are look
where it's gone the internet very
networks yeah like we could have a
podcast network skinny that'd be fun
maybe sometime not today though not
today I really want to hear you guys
chime in okay so I want to hear your
opinions on it if you were aware of this
what you think and if you agree with us
or or what you what you think this could
lead to because like I am strongly in
the in the team of believing that this
will cause waves whatever they are what
however small they are it's going to do
something and I want to know what you
guys think and not just on YouTube not
just on YouTube this changes more than
just YouTube absolutely this idea of
adhering a you know franchise format to
new media has serious implications for
you know things that don't even exist
yet yes for absolutely
for the next YouTube that's fine the
next snapchat though this this has
serious implications for new media as a
whole and you know it's gonna be
interesting to watch and go down but I
will forever be in the boat that like
everybody do everything and [ __ ]
everything [ __ ] all the rules that's
what's cool about the Internet is that
everybody is a chicken with their head
cut off nobody knows what they're doing
and if anybody tells you they know [ __ ]
about
they're lying nobody knows anything
they're either a liar or they've
successfully time-traveled one of the
two which I wouldn't count either just
there are those people that think they
know everything that's sure that's the
third option and they don't [ __ ]
those people are the ones that say you
know new media guru and they're in their
Twitter bio and they have ten followers
I got new media guru a philanthropist um
yeah yeah definitely so just let us know
guys and um you know thank you for
always hanging out with us and listening
to what we have to say is you know
nearly an hour every week we just we
just sit here and talk about our
opinions on things and we we cannot
emphasize to you enough how much we
appreciate you chillin out with us and
hearing us talk and discuss things and
be want to do this for a very long time
because we do we want to do this for as
long as we can because this is an
amazing thing that we get to do and
outlet it's an amazing outlet like we
it's almost like sort of therapy we get
to just like talk what's on our mind and
like express and discuss and it's so
good and you guys get to watch it
completely unfettered somebody shows up
and hangs out with ya which we're we're
working on getting a few more exciting
guests so hold on for that but until
then you'll just have to deal with us
okay check out our sponsors if you if
you have a second pod survey com /jj
takes five minutes it's a survey about
sponsors for the podcast very meta but
it does help get sponsors that you guys
will like on the podcast so it helps you
helps us help to everyone so check them
out that's mid-roll and headspace take
the take 10 challenge meditate for 10
days for free see how you like it guided
meditation right from your iphone go to
headspace comm slash Jenna Julian thank
you guys for hanging out yeah thanks and
we'll see you guys for another one next
week I hope
took anything at what I said this I
think you're pretty clear I hope we're
clear I feel like we are lovely Internet
and I love everybody everybody love
everybody
most importantly if my love ever place
thanks for hanging out guys